pourquoi vous avez fait ce livre alors
effectivement pour part à recompter mon
parcours et raconter comment j'en suis
venu à la liberté d'expression
comment je suis venu à défendre la
liberté d'expression et comment depuis
un petit une certaine soif de liberté
liberté géographique liberté dans tous
les sens du terme est la plus grande des
libertés est celle de la liberté
d'expression a raconté à la fois sur mon
île à la fois dans mon éducation à la
fois dans tous les postes que j'ai pu
occuper en façon par le sèche pour
volonté de vos origines aussi incroyable
de la guadeloupe bah oui mais non il ya
venons la guadeloupe et yalaoui vous est
un doux mélange quand même fou noir à
votre maman ah oui exactement c'est vrai
que je raconte dans le livre que je suis
né presque entre deux cocotiers en
guadeloupe dès c'est caricatural mais si
pour montrer aussi que la république et
la france permet aussi d'avancer au delà
des clichés et puis c'est vrai que dans
un ami dans un shaker on a mis un peu de
congolais un peu de breton un peu deux
vietnamiens un peu d'indiens de madras
on a secoué sa donne à un peu de kelly
un peu de christine kelly et c'est vrai
que c'est ça la guadeloupe c'est ça la
france et pourtant je peux aller aux
états unis on me prend pour une
américaine à cuba on me prend pour une
cubaine au maroc comme un propos une
marocaine en egypte on me prend pour une
libyenne et en france on me demande d'où
je viens
vous parler de nos grands-parents et de
l'importance de leur éducation il était
je crois enseignants et vous parle delà
de la couleur de la couleur de peau vous
nous expliquer comme quoi ça ou c'est à
dire comme mes parents m'ont toujours
alors éducation très stricte très
strictes protestante où l'apparence
n'est pas importante mais mes parents
m'ont toujours appris que c'est
l'intérieur qui compte l'apparence est
trompeuse et la beauté even sert versets
de la bible mais j'ai été élevé comme ça
et c'est incroyable parce que ça m'a
formé ça m'a forgé ça m'a permis de
grandir à l'abri des critiques sur mon
apparence et à l'abri des valorisations
de mon apparence et de me forger une
certaine carapace et que l'on m'appelle
noiraude comme je raconte dans le livre
je
sais news ma couleur de peau si c'était
voilà je reste à la barre de ces
critiques parce que je cultive mes
valeurs intérieures si peu que j'en ai
ils vous ont dit là l'intelligence n'a
pas de couleur exactement elles étaient
les gens' n'a pas de couleur et je pense
que l'être humain devrait oublier
parfois justement tout ce qui est en
apparence extérieure et chivu catégorise
dans certains endroits d'un certain
niveau social d'un certain
et vous interdis certain niveau culturel
où certains accès dans la société et je
pense que chaque être humain reste un
être humain et doit pouvoir mériter
d'accéder aux plus grands postes dans la
société d'accéder à la plus grande
liberté d'expression et ne pas brimer à
cette liberté qui est souvent sans
expression alors je les ai quand même où
vous appelle la noiraude du service oui
ça s'était passé c'était dingue ou de
canal ya bien moi je dis c'est terrible
et oui la personne ne me suis-je dit pas
ça méchamment ce nouveau n'y voit pas de
racisme sur comment on peut dire une
chose pareille et oui et sur lci en fait
c'était une jeune femme qui m'avait dit
tu viens faire le ménage chez moi aulas
et c'était entre deux jt on apprend via
les inattendus d'exploser du diable
écoute mais ferme ta bouche pas oui
comme ta gueule même carrément
en fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que
tu te dis waouh tu as des palpitations
si tu te dis mais comment on peut citer
une amie commune c'était
vraiment s'était alors fait mais par
fait très décomposé oui mais si tu
t'énerves est pas justement quand on est
agressée comme ça c'est violent de table
ne sait jamais ça peut arriver avant
mais voici à peu ce dernier mais mais ce
que j'ai fait c'est que je me suis dit
que bien je m'énerve ou bien je
l'insulté ou bien je souris et je la
laisse à son mépris et je ne me laisse
pas enfermer dans l'humiliation de
l'autre je ne me laisse pas enfermer
dans l'aliénation de l'autre et je fais
mon chemin et je trouve que c'est une
grande liberté pour reprendre le mot que
de ne pas se laisser dans les critiques
n'ont pas fermé dans l'église il ya
quand même pelouse utilise souvent le
seul noir oui alors alors évidemment et
vous savez
honnêtement je me suis pas à chaque fois
je comptais pas des noirs autour de moi
la prison je suis arrivé je sais pas
s'il ya des noirs pa je me pose pas la
question
mais je ne me pose pas la question c'est
surtout qu'on est tous des êtres humains
on est tous on a deux yeux de bras de
pied enfin on est là et c'est ce qui est
important pour moi mais on me faisait
remarquer souvent que j'étais la seule
noire mais on me faisait remarquer que
j'étais la première noire lci mais on me
faisait remarquer que j'étais la
première noire au 16 mai mira et ces
termes c'est
accepter normalement il n'y a pas eu de
quolibets ou de remarques désobligeantes
quand même
ça ça a été le pire moment à payerne à
tous
ces mensonges et cetera sur moi en
permanence mais justement là où j'ai pu
surprendre c'est parce que je me suis
jamais laissé enfermer dans les
critiques et là où on m'attaquait je
souriais mais je me disais que non tu ne
m'auras pas là tu m'auras pas là je veux
montrer qu'il ya une méritocratie en
france je veux montrer qu'on peut être
compétent et avancer on peut prendre
plus de temps on peut tomber mais il
faut se relever pour montrer que ce
n'est pas parce qu'on veut critique
qu'on va rester enfermé dans les
critiques de notre mais au csa oui j'ai
beaucoup souffert et vous dites dans
votre livre que j'avais perdu votre
liberté du journaliste à une période de
vie oui ça veut dire quoi parlant ça
c'était lorsque j'étais au cs parce que
au csa on a un devoir de réserve on ne
peut plus dire ce qu'on veut on est
obligé de passer par l'autorité de
régulation et par tous les autres
membres du conseil pour pouvoir
s'exprimer sur un sujet sur un dossier
interdiction de parler de certains votes
qui ont eu lieu donc là oui j'avais
perdu ma liberté en tant que journaliste
mais que j'ai bien retrouver justement
parlé et m'a dit moi juste au csa qu'il
est votre plus grande fierté a frappé ce
que c'est que ces samatan sedar com
c'est un anglais ce qui régule et qui
s'intéresse aux contenus des programmes
demande oui
mais ma plus grande fierté ça a été de
dire qu' il faut convaincre plutôt que
contraindre là encore j'ai été un peu
une rebelle mais là encore tous les
patrons de chaînes et de radios à alger
une très très bonne relation avec eux
parce que je disais tout le temps que le
csa s'est pas uniquement un organisme
qui est là pour censurer mais pour aider
l'audiovisuel a avancé a explosé au
niveau international comme ça les gars
alors il ya eu il ya eu les théâtres
zemmour qui étaient quand même
compliquées des ronces et un peu texte
et c'est même moi j'avais parfois du mal
à certains propos et vous avez fait
l'objet de beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de critiques je
voudrais vous chez pascal praud vous
disiez que certains de vos amis ont
reproché de travailler avec zemmour ah
oui mais beaucoup beaucoup d'amis m'ont
reproché travail existe alors j'aime
bien parce que quelqu'un comme vous avez
eu la gentillesse de me faire part de
vos romain ajout d appeler donc vers
choquer ou je sais pas quoi je comprends
très bien mais c'est ça qui est
important pourquoi christine tu es là
pourquoi est ce que tu fais cette
émission est ce que là tu n'a pas été
choqué oui mais je suis pas obligé de le
montrer est-ce que là tu penses que
c'est ta place oui c'est ma place je
vais t'expliquer pourquoi mais beaucoup
n'ont même pas voulu discuter avant même
l'émission avant même la première
émission voilà je recevais déjà des
coups de fil d'indiens que ce n'était
pas ma plainte on vous a peut-être un
peu trop neutre avec eric zemmour ne pas
le malade de pas lui rentrer dedans de
pas mais en même temps ce n'est pas
votre rôle dans la mission pour moi en
fait le travail d'un journaliste c'est
d'être neutre ou bien moins que j'ai
oublié la définition du journalisme
ou bien peut être éditorialistes
sculpture aura des fonctions différentes
mais pour moi le travail d'un
journaliste et d'être neutre essaie de
comprendre et de laisser le
téléspectateur jugé lui va se dire tiens
je n'aime pas du tout ce qu'a dit
zemmour tient ça peut-être ça me fait
réfléchir et dé tous voulaient tout
public n'est pas dupe nombreux le public
n'est pas dit que c'est lui qui décide
c'est lui qui va au bout du bout à faire
trier le grain de l'ivraie et c'est lui
qui compte pour intelligent et qu'il
faut dire qu'effectivement il faut
qu'ils puissent il faut qu'ils puissent
seul mot pouvoir décider il faut pas
qu'ils puissent aller uniquement cherché
sur le net sur les réseaux sociaux bien
le dark web d'information
particulière ça justement la pensée
d'eric zemmour c'est une pensée qui
existent en france ou pas la laisser
leur exprimer mais la canaliser et sans
pour autant rentrer dedans être
forcément compte mais modérée canaliser
empêché de dépasser de déborder au
niveau de la loi sauf que il est blanc
paraît très bien mais cette émission est
la présence de ces mots vous avez pas vu
quand même des gros soucis vous avez
deux gardes du corps c'est une
protection policière à ise coutin bah
ils sont là ils sont là bonjour je dois
aller me garder
les couloirs cette protection policière
c'est très compliqué de vivre avec des
gardes du corps 24 heures sur 24 d'abord
qu'elle était là la teneur des menaces
et des menaces de mort d d d d eau la
première c'est on va simplement vous et
ganges et si vous allez tel endroit ou
tel endroit je veux dire bourru mais
également parce que les sting et d'été
nous en arrivions là des menaces de mort
oui voilà mais vous c'était plus que des
ménages ont été très sérieux oui on
avait beaucoup et c est après bon ça
s'est calmé on a eu encore il n'ya pas
très longtemps on en avait parlé
ici mais là ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on pouvait avoir des menaces de mort
avant parce qu'on avait pris une
certaine position qui avait choqué déjà
même là on se dit mais c'est pas
justifiée mais lorsque comme ophélie
meunier sur m6 qui parlait de roubaix
qui a présenté un reportage ou bien
comme moi dans cette émission on ne
prend pas position et cauna des menaces
de mort il va falloir se poser des
questions qui peut dire pour qui je vote
qui peut dire quelle est ma part c'est
mon livre c'est de dire pour qui vous ne
votez pas ah bon kyaw y apprend coupé me
vient l'idée quand même
une façon de dire sincèrement c'est que
c'est que je ne m'aime dents mais mon
plus proche entourage personne le cmr
pensée politique et je m'applique à ne
pas la donner donc je trouve
inadmissible dont cette démocratie qui
est la france qu'on puisse vous menacer
de mort vous disent que vous avez exposé
avec soro au quotidien pardon si vous
avez peur au quotidien
plus maintenant un petit filet à la
prunelle de vos yeux c'est compliqué
comme ont expliqué ses petites-filles
bah voila je suis maintenant j'ai deux
gardes du corps on pourra plus faire
comme pas enlevé avant et simplement au
restaurant et au cinéma à tout ce qu'on
fait quand on la garde du corps ou quand
on le fait il faut prévenir faut par des
parcours moi j'ai eu des gardes du corps
une époque c'était une très chiant oui
alors effectivement je lui ai expliqué
petit à petit à ma fille par exemple
quand vous marchez dans la rue il m'a
dit ah oui mais pour qu'ils changent
tout le temps ils sourient ils sont
gentils avec toi je dis attention ils
sont pas tous gentils cinq minutes après
y avait quelqu'un qui m'avait insulté
donc je lui ai expliqué et honnêtement
au début j'avais refusé un peu la
protection et finalement j'ai fini par
l'accepter et honnêtement ça a été la
plus belle nuit de ma vie parce que je
me suis rendu compte que je dormais pas
très bien merci bourgault christine
kelly alors peut pas ne peut pas parler
fait dans votre livre forcément c'est un
principe parler de cyril hanouna
alors je vous faire lire ce que vous
avez écrit sur cnn ou la wii ce que je
ne sais pas lire et
surtout je n'ai pas mes lunettes ça ne
m'arrange pas je trouve ça très joli
vous avez écrit alors j'espère que c'est
une bonne retranscription d'écoutés oui
alors quant à cyril hanouna si souvent
décrit comme un enfant roi un sale gosse
il s'est révélé un homme intuitif pourvu
d'une énergie vitale à faire pâlir
d'envié les bâtisseurs d'empiré il est
encore ce travailleur méticuleux dont le
caractère généreux il n'en finit pas de
surprendre un humain très humain qu'il
ne reçoit les maximes de son action ni
d'un maître ni de personne merci des
libertés sans hésitation
[Applaudissements]